[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 en esta segunda
semana de invasión de ucrania dedicamos
de nuevo este programa a seguir las
consecuencias de la guerra en el mundo
cultural empezando con el cerco en el
que se encuentran los artistas rusos si
no se pronuncian contra la guerra son
boicoteados
internacionalmente pero si lo hacen
apagan el precio en casa el metropolitan
opera de nueva york por ejemplo excluyó
de sus conciertos la cantante estrella
anna netrebko diciendo que ella tardó en
tomar partido
una presión también denunciada por el
director de orquesta tugán sokhiev
director musical a la vez del teatro
bolshói de moscú y de la orquesta
nacional del capitolio y toulouse ciudad
gemela de izquierda dimitió de sus dos
puestos al mismo tiempo por no
expresarse sobre la guerra declarando
que era incapaz de elegir entre sus
músicos franceses y rusos pero pueden
todos los artistas rusos adoptar una
postura oficial pues es complicado
porque en rusia se ha aprobado una nueva
ley que restringe la libertad de
expresión hasta 15 años de prisión
contra quienes difunden información
falsa sobre las fuerzas armadas rusas de
momento esta ley se dirige
principalmente a los medios de
comunicación pero las represalias contra
los artistas rusos son muy reales la
semana pasada les informamos de la
dimisión de la directora del teatro
estatal y centro cultural may erbol de
moscú elena kowalska ya para protestar
contra la guerra y bueno todo el centro
ha sido cerra por el estado ruso
entonces es el boicot a los artistas
rusos la mejor arma o una pregunta
compleja el famoso director de orquesta
daniel barenboim advirtió durante un
concierto benéfico del peligro de
condenar la cultura rusa por la política
del presidente putin a daniel barenboim
cuyos abuelos de origen ucraniano y
bielorruso huyeron de los pogromos
antisemistas de principios del siglo 20
explicó al público su sorpresa por la
cancelación de un simposio sobre
dostoievski en italia por la
nacionalidad rusa del autor y también
por la prohibición de polonia de tocar
música rusa de cualquier siglo no
escuchamos la cultura rusa no es lo
mismo que la política rusa y política
debemos condenar la política en voz alta
y clara y distanciarnos de ella
inequívocamente
pero no debemos permitir una casa de
brujas contra el pueblo y la cultura
rusa
voy con las nuevas prohibiciones y
boicots por ejemplo de la música y la
literatura rusas en varios países
europeos me evocan las peores
asociaciones de
asociación
por parte de los artistas ucranianos se
siente una urgencia en seguir tocando
bailando y produciendo obras el
miércoles 9 de marzo la plaza de la
independencia de kiev plaza maidana se
convirtió en un escenario improvisado de
la orquesta sinfónica clásica de la
capital ucraniana y actuó aún más
simbólico en esta ciudad asediada por
rusia tocaron la oda a la alegría
el movimiento más famoso de la novedad
sinfonía de ludwig van beethoven y el
himno de la unión europea
afuera de ucrania también cada actuación
tiene un sabor activismo y resistencia
para los artistas ucranianos como los
bailarines del quier city ballet desde
el 3 de marzo la ciudad de parís
consiguió una residencia ilimitada en el
teatro del iac ley a esta compañía que
llegó a francia el día antes de la
invasión rusa de ucrania a pesar de la
angustia por sus seres queridos estos
bailarines convertidos en exiliados
forzados de la noche a la mañana se
alegran de poder seguir enseñando y
actuando
y decimos a nuestros bailarines sobre
todo antes de subir al escenario que
tienen una oportunidad única de
compartir su voz de compartir su amor no
tenemos odio llevamos la luz es nuestro
trabajo llevar la luz a los demás llevar
ese amor de seleccionar
y seguir produciendo arte también tiene
su papel en la sensibilización de la
opinión pública como suele ocurrir
además de la guerra de las armas hay una
guerra de ideas esto es lo que
generalmente se llama software poder
blando que incluye la influencia
cultural de un país y de sus artistas
como la rapera ucraniana hay una hay una
una de las únicas que escribe actúa en
su lengua materna y ahora desde el
pueblo de sus padres a unos 50
kilómetros de quiera liderar su
resistencia en sus redes sociales
publicando vídeos de explicación del
conflicto y llamadas al apoyo y no sólo
los artistas ucranianos se sienten
investidos por esta misión de
sensibilización las voces solidarias de
los georgia nos en particular que
también han la guerra contra rusia
resuenan en los últimos días el director
artístico de la casa de alta costura
balenciaga de natalia dedicó su último
desfile al público ucraniano bajo una
tormenta de nieve y fuertes vientos los
modelos recorrieron la pasarela portando
bolsas de basura como las que llenan
apresuradamente las personas que huyen
de la guerra dos siluetas amarillas y
azules concluyeron el desfile recordando
a la bandera ucraniana por su parte la
pianista franco georgiana khatia
buniatishvili
participó en el gran concierto todos
unidos por ucrania organizado el 8 de
marzo en francia unos días después de
tocar también el himno ucraniano al
piano con la orquesta de cámara de parís
en homenaje al pueblo ucraniano y con
estas notas nos despedimos gracias por
su confianza y cuídense
[Música]